[Music]
It Was a Race Against Time to find four
young children who survived a plane
crash in the Colombian Amazon
the discovery of the wreckage sparked a
frantic search that transfixed a nation
as Rescuers combed through the depths of
inhospitable jungle for over a month
[Music]
a military leader who oversaw the search
and the children's great uncle sat down
with the journal to provide a first-hand
account of the harrowing Survival Story
[Music]
the children's ordeal began early on May
1st when the engine of the small plane
they were traveling in cut out over
virgin rainforest in southern Colombia
the Cessna 206 fell plowed through trees
and slammed into the jungle two weeks
after the crash soon after indigenous
volunteers located the wreckage
Colombian Army Commandos arrived at the
scene and found three lifeless bodies
the pilot an indigenous leader and a
young woman named Magdalena mukutoy the
children's mother is
the plane's manifest showed that the
four siblings two sisters ages 13 and 9
a five-year-old boy and a baby girl had
also been aboard but they were nowhere
to be found
Colombian Armed Forces General Pedro
Sanchez who oversaw the rescue operation
said soldiers inspecting the crash scene
noticed something hopeful the tale of
the plane was intact is
mama
um
meanwhile the four siblings found
themselves lost and alone in a
forbidding environment
foreign
Tiempo
intense search codenamed Operation HOPE
was launched involving 11 aircraft 113
Commandos and 92 indigenous trackers
many of whom fish and hunt in the
regiones
soon after the plane was discovered the
Searcher said they found a baby bottle
about three miles from where the plane
went down in the days that followed they
reported finding more clues scissors the
tennis shoes of a small boy and a
child's footprint in the mud
caseus
is
relatives in the country's Army said
that over the 40 days the children
wandered the rainforest they survived on
the small supply of food they scavenged
from the luggage that was on the plane
as well as nuts and wild fruit found on
the forest floor
[Music]
when a group of indigenous trackers
crisscross through the jungle on June
9th they noticed something
sombre
photographs provided by the Colombian
Armed Forces show soldiers tending to
the children
they were lifted out by helicopter and
taken to the small town of San Jose del
guaviare in southern Colombia where the
country's president said they received
medical attention
relatives celebrated when news of the
rescue came through
and damos
the next day the children were flown to
awaiting ambulances in Bogota and
transferred to a military hospital where
doctors say they are surrounded by
relatives and recovering
is
Sanchez attributes the children's
survival to four factors the desire to
live their strong immunity indigenous
knowledge and good health
foreign
[Music]